what is a hunter why is a hunter who
is a hunter who are you why aren't you
subscribed to the new world review which
will grant you regular hunt onto content
uploaded straight into your youtube feed
all of these questions and more
are about to be answered hello and
welcome to the new order of your source
for everything anime and manga and today
we have a very simple simple question to
tackle
in regards to hunter hunter simple yet
surprisingly vague given that the series
in question
doesn't truly deep dive into it but we
are going to ask ourselves
what is a hunter now before we go into
this i want to make clear that i am not
concerned with what is the hunter
association i have a whole different
video planned for that detailing its
structure purpose and internal politics
which of course
is managed by hunters however in this
video we are much more concerned with
the membership of the association itself
and what
exactly are hunters well in the
strictest technical definition
a hunter is simply an individual who has
been issued a license from the hunter
association and required by its bylaws
to always be in pursuit of something or
someone
or someplace or anything as long as
pursuit is happening well that
does a hunter may apparently it's not at
all a simple position to achieve though
and it does require the successful
completion of the hunter exam
an annual event held to source new
talent into the ranks of the association
which are notorious for its exceptional
physical and mental standards
as well as a high risk of fatality when
undertaking it
in fact these standards are so
incredibly difficult to meet that it is
entirely possible to have years where
zero candidates actually
managed to pass the exam and just for
some perspective on this the number of
licensed hunters in this series totaled
just over 600
at the conclusion of the 13th german
election arc however this number is
judged purely by valid vote totals and
does not account for the hunters who did
not participate in the election like say
illumi zoldic for example however this
is still an extraordinarily low number
in comparison to the world at large i
mean for example the nation of escorto
alone had at least
5 million residents and that is far from
a densely populated area of the world
like york new city so hunters are pretty
incredibly rare i would estimate that
there are
at most a few thousand of them in the
world but once this grueling marathon of
an exam has been completed
candidates are then issued with a shiny
hunter license the mere possession of
which grants its wielder unparalleled
freedom within this world for example a
license holder is able to access
95 of first-class public transport at no
cost as well as granted immediate access
to 90
of the human known world provided with
an online facility to gather or sell
intelligence and they are also granted
what is effectively
legal immunity from the act of murder so
it is quite literally a license to kill
although there are circumstances where
consequences for murder will be
invoked just not by the various legal
systems around the world instead it
would be done by a disciplinary
committee of the association itself and
it's usually only invoked when a hunter
targets a fellow hunter
now finally even after having been
issued a license this is a provisional
act and a hunter will not be fully
recognized until they have mastered the
basic principles of nen a super secret
art form that focuses on harnessing and
deploying life energy also known as aura
so with all of that in mind i suppose
you could say that the basic idea of a
hunter is an individual
granted easy access to the world with
diplomatic immunity for their actions
and equipped with superhuman abilities
for the purpose of completing their task
whatever that is
so i suppose in a way you could say that
hunters are select individuals whose
talents are recognized and then
cultivated in theory for the benefit of
mankind i say
in theory because at the same time a
hunter's goal can directly contribute to
the decline of humanity so as much as
hunters are highly revered in this world
there is also good reason to fear them
as well but exactly what hunters are in
pursuit of is going to make up the bulk
of this video because there are a lot
and i mean a lot
of different sub genres of hunting some
of which are very common niche
professions to delve into whilst others
exist seemingly only to characterize one
individual but starting here at the very
lowest ranks we have rookie hunters now
this branch is the only type of hunter
that exists as an exception to the first
association bylaw because rookies do not
actively need to be in pursuit of
something although they often are for
example gone is a rookie hunter and he
spent the large majority of the series
in search of his father jing and
according to association standards that
would be perfectly acceptable
on the other hand we have kilauea who is
a rookie hunter as well but he does not
spend his time in the series pursuing
anything in particular i mean you could
probably
say something wanky about how oh he's
just trying to
find himself which i'm pretty sure i
have said in a previous video but it
doesn't quite fulfill the association
criteria and then leoria was also
classified as a rookie hunter because
he's put that entire career on hold to
study medicine but basically a rookie
hunter is a licensed individual who
lacks an area of specialty
although most hunters would not spend
too long in this stage as it is highly
uncommon for a candidate to actually
pass the exam
without an extreme drive in some form so
in regards to some specialties by far
the most common profession we've seen in
the series is that of a blacklist hunter
and depending on what translation you've
seen or read these individuals are also
referred to as bounty hunters which as
the name implies mean they generally
spend their time tracking down wanted
criminals and the best example we would
have of a blacklist hunter is of course
karapika who effectively dedicated his
life to bringing justice to the phantom
troop which represent an entire band of
class a bounties however as part of his
ongoing quest to recover the scarlet
eyes of his clan krapika also shifts his
focus
to the entirety of the body park
collector's black market and here he may
not necessarily be hunting figures
technically classified as criminals but
those who are still blatantly involved
in illegal activities another famous
blacklist hunter would be saiyutho a
member of the zodiacs
and his particular abilities are very
well suited for this task given that he
can deprive targets of their sight
hearing and speech you know the old see
no evil hear no evil speak no evil thing
and other well-known blacklist hunters
in the series would include bernout
lippo
and bushidora ambitious and very notably
blacklist hunters are not to be confused
with
crime hunters the only example of which
we have at this point would be mizeiston
because while both do center around
criminal activities a crime hunter acts
as more of a detective than a simple
bounty seeker now the next most common
typing we have come across would be that
of a beast hunter meaning those who
specialize in the study and potentially
capture of fauna and good old knuckle is
a great example of a beast hunter who
dedicated himself to the cause of the
chimera ant extermination not
necessarily to actually exterminate the
ants but to seek to understand them
and their presence in this world so
knuckle has a true curiosity and empathy
for the creatures of this planet outside
of humanity beast hunters are also
generally divided into further
subclassifications like
pockel who was labelled as a fantastic
beast hunter and he dedicated his
pursuits to the documentation of unknown
species and similarly shoot was
introduced as an unidentified beast
hunter which at face value
sounds very much like pockel's
designation but shoot study focused more
on the mythical paranormal and
supernatural entities turning to the
realm of medicine now we can identify
disease hunters a category that so far
only includes cheedle and sanbika the
latter of which is specifically
recognized as a virus hunter but i
suppose you could essentially call
this a branch of super science hunters
who have near limitless resources at
their disposal to focus on finding cures
for the various diseases that have
plagued humanity on the other end of the
spectrum we also have gourmet hunters
which are much more focused on
accentuating the pleasures of life
rather than providing the necessities to
live it gourmet hunters typically travel
the world in search of exotic
ingredients and furthering the world of
high-class cuisine a gourmet hunter is
of course
usually also a highly accomplished chef
in their own right with a
wildly sophisticated palette as we saw
in menchie although a gourmet hunted
need not be so demanding in this area as
seen in buhari also lynn or durv was
classified as a gourmet hunter which is
very interesting because she was a close
friend of isaac netro
and even traveled with him to the dark
continent so who knows what delicious
madness she picked up there and has
since applied to the world of cookery
now next up we have a very basic form of
hunting which would be treasure hunters
who obviously travel the world in search
of very valuable objects like biski who
dedicated her career specifically to
hunting precious stones
whilst kansai of the zodiacs has only
been described as more of a general
treasure hunter along the same lines
though we have the indiana joneses of
the hunthunter world being relicantes
not to be confused with the 1999 tier
career series reliconta or maybe it is
to be confused with it
because their purposes are very similar
as relic hunters are glorified super
archaeologists of the world dedicated to
uncovering preserving and learning from
ancient ruins although a further goal
has also been identified by satots which
is to revive ancient societies which is
very intriguing and just while we're
here pjeon of the zodiacs was identified
as a paleograph hunter who specifically
specializes in learning and translating
ancient or lost languages which no it's
not
one for one connected to relic hunting
but these areas would have significant
crossover that very much does it for
confirmed groups of hunters though there
are of course
many other brands however they only have
one confirmed member amongst their ranks
thus far like for example clock is a
botanical hunter which is the flora
incarnation of a beast hunter and you
would assume that there are likely
others with that specialty but
we don't know another very likely broad
area of expertise would be the realm of
sea hunters which is the profession
moral inhabits and it's a big ass
because it basically encompasses
anything to do with the sea be it flora
fauna treasures nautical studies
whatever if it is in or on water then it
is morals territory but then things also
start to get very very specific
to the point where it seems likely that
there is only one individual within the
association who can embody that label
given like gigshot the hakka hunter who
deals exclusively with cybercrime or
cutie beauty who is called a cute hunter
whose entire goal is to enhance and
maintain the beauty of others
which shows that hunting can be a very
superficial practice
and then on the odd occasion we also
have titles given with no explanation
whatsoever like
sacho who is labelled as a problem
hunter an incredibly vague title that
could refer to
almost anything in the world it might
imply that his specialty has to do with
puzzles logistics
mathematics i don't know whatever maybe
all of them but also
maybe none of them in more recent years
though two other very broad categories
of hunters have popped up in the series
the first of which are provisional
hunters
now this is not the same as holding
provisional status after completing the
exam
in order to begin then training no these
provisional hunters were temporarily
licensed for the purpose of the dark
continent expedition and they were
specifically designated to the personnel
of the karkin princes furthermore they
did not require any knowledge much less
mastery of men to achieve this status
although many of them do have a
background in the art form regardless
like data who guards fourth prince
haradnick and currently there are
roughly 150 personnel who have been
granted the status of provisional hunter
in addition to this another branch that
was brought to our attention is that of
temp hunters which are probably best
described as individuals subcontracted
by the association although in stark
contrast to the new brand of
aforementioned provisional hunters
temp hunters do have an extensive
background in men and they can very much
come to rival professional hunters in
terms of skill however they are not
professionally licensed and i suppose
they act as more of associates of the
organization or in more
capitalistic terms they would be the
casual workers of this business
enterprise and despite the fact that
there are approximately 200 temp hunters
in existence the only ones that we've
been exposed to
were those present as part of beyond
netro's sneaky expedition team and these
figures were assumedly hand-picked by
pariston hill for their very specific
specialties and seen as an essential
element for survival on the dark
continent
but despite their fearsome nature there
is of course a stigma attached to being
a temp hunter and the very existence of
this level
is often mocked by fully licensed
hunters but having said all of this
very sad fact of hunter hunter is that
the large majority of hunters we've met
in the series are completely
unclassified
in terms of their exact profession even
some surprising figures like kite whose
research we became a direct part of have
no official label as of yet
or even the former chairman himself
isaac netara we never actually found out
what his specialty field was
and of course this also includes
licensed hunters who have completed the
exam
simply for the convenience that the
license granted them like i mentioned
dilemmy earlier but hisoka also comes
under this umbrella and they are figures
who very much go on to undermine the
broad goal of the association at large
and for all intents and purposes are
completely encouraged to do so because
that's what hunters do
they encourage excellence and excellence
is not always a good thing but that is
kind of it for hunters it's hard to
believe that we have so much information
regarding them and yet
it's so vague and disconnected at the
same time i mean in the end a hunter is
probably described as a world-class
professional given the resources and
skills they need to further a particular
cause whatever that may be and generally
yeah that does lead to great benefits to
humanity but it can also be a purely
selfish pursuit
and in the worst case scenario you are
giving individuals near limitless
resources to directly undermine society
but what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more hunt onto
content then please to go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
hunt hunter glory delivered straight to
your youtube feed but for now this has
been the new world review and i'll see
you next time